from poker face to Joker face Lady Gaga
gave her little monsters a sneak peek of
a Harley Quinn in the upcoming Joker
Sequel and the reaction was fantabulous
Harley Quinn is easily one of the most
dynamic characters in DC's extensive
roster of Heroes and bodies and plenty
of stars have taken a cracker playing
the unstable and heavily armed
villainous
go Robbie notably debuted a portrayal of
Dr harleen quinzel in 2016's Suicide
Squad she laid to reprise her role in
both Birds of Prey and James Gunn's half
sequel half do-over The Suicide Squad
you're a hero to me
as well as to my people this might get
me confused
at the same time Kaylee Cuoco began
voicing an animated version of the
character in 2019 for the Harley Quinn
TV series Now Lady Gaga is stepping up
to the plate to play Quinn and Todd
Phillips sequel to Joker starring
Joaquin Phoenix and an oscar-winning
performance as Arthur Fleck Joker
tracked the origins of how a wannabe
comedian became an iconic super villain
with its heady hallucinations and
choreographed dance sequences Joker had
a bit of the spirit of Lady Gaga
stylized and surreal brand of artistry
so it made sense when the pop star took
to Twitter in August 2022 to confirm her
involvement in the upcoming sequel
titled Joker Foley Adu with Foley Adu
said to be a musical Lady Gaga is
arguably a top-tier choice to play as
Harley Quinn even Margot Robbie endorse
sarcastic decision noting that Quinn is
an enjoying character open to
interpretation on February 14 2023 Gaga
tweeted out a first look preview image
of herself a square and it's Gaga's
character a staring or struck at
Phoenix's Arthur with some clown makeup
smudge on her face as she clasps his
head in her hands unsurprisingly no one
is as excited to see Gaga morph into the
villain as her devoted fans given the
date of its release Gaga's Army of
little monsters received his photo as a
Valentine's Day treat and needless to
say fire emojis heart emojis and gasps
of mother will plan to fall in her
Twitter replies one fan posted no
trailer no plots no character
description just one Lady Gaga shot on
the Joker said that has everyone moving
that's impact other users are even
hoping that Gaga's multi-hyphenate
Talent will earn her first Oscar acting
nomination since 2018's A Star is Born
cementing her status as a Hollywood
powerhouse on Reddit too among users of
the DC Cinematic Universe subreddit
responses are largely positive to this
first photo of the pop Superstar as
Harley Quinn for example in a thread
dedicated to her preview image one user
wrote Lady Gaga can bring the weird
energy so I think this should be pretty
rad this comment alone received more
than 600 upvotes similarly another user
argued that good chemistry is already
apparent between Gaga and Joaquin
Phoenix meanwhile users of a general pop
culture discussion subreddit are
likewise stoked about Gaga as Quinn one
user posted about the image I don't
think I was sold on her as Harley until
this her whole face embodies a character
wow I'm actually getting excited for
this one now fans will have to wait a
little while longer to see Gaga
transform into Quinn on the big screen
however Joker Folia 2 is scheduled for
release on October 4th 2024
foreign